[Music]
welcome back to
the record where we talk about whatever
we want
your anime back hey ryan may we just
dude okay during lunch i thought this
was a dope ass conversation but when we
were doing their walks
guys were like if you had to do
crime which one would you do because
everyone here
i think like if you had to live off of
like a criminal racket sustainable crime
racket and there is a fascination
especially in american culture of like
easy fast money there's so much shows
and
what is it about outlaw ism that's like
so attractive
it's the this it's the american spirit
dude we want to see people [ __ ] win
and get away with [ __ ] yeah beat the man
and beat the system yeah yeah
that's exactly what it is yeah i agree
because we create a lot of content on
just like android revolution
cowboys and yep yeah gangster [ __ ]
but i even grew up on like hong kong
triad films
asian mob films so there's just that
like allure yeah across internationally
i feel like
ocean's 11 those were huge movies yeah
yeah yeah they're like
sexy men jeez dude the fast movies
they're all heist movies now
yeah they're all criminal movies they're
all stealing [ __ ] we're all helping the
us government now
yeah whatever [ __ ] snitches yeah
exactly
we're glorifying snitches now hoping the
us government destabilized third world
countries fantastic
good job dude do you guys see a
difference between
governments and criminal organizations
and for governments is legal that's all
i see
that's it but people make it a morality
issue
an ethical issue and i'm just like it's
just they're in power
it's just legal jargon it's it's a bunch
of words on some paper and some
room somewhere that can be blown up or
whatever why do you think it's a touchy
subject though
because i think people want to believe
in the good of the world
like i belong to a country that isn't
currently doing good like patriotism
yeah but i feel like for me the way i
view the world i think the world
is just like a wild forest right like
the animal
kingdom and i think everyone just wants
to assert their rules
so religions no this is my rules this is
how the world is and the government no
this is how the rural
world should be and then the mob no this
is how the world should be
and like when you control the culture
you control the people yeah religion
right if
yeah like i if i'm the king of these
people
because of like i'm the i'm the prophet
or whatever i'm the religious leader
yeah then you control like thousands of
people yeah because even like us when
we're in high school
like marijuana was like heroin right
and then so you're like oh [ __ ] we yeah
you can't be smoking weed or nothing
like that and then now
it's like nothing yeah and they're just
like what so just because someone
literally took
whiteout on their [ __ ] the law and
okay no no so it's like so if laws and
morality can flip-flop
so much it's just about how you play the
game oh and bro i mean
in congress there's a slush fund to pay
sexual harassment
victims like pages who come into
congress and they work like as interns
and stuff
they have there's a fund there's a
sexual harassment fund much fun yeah and
they pay
out all of these pages these people who
get sexually harassed by congress people
and like their and their other workers
and stuff in their offices
and nobody [ __ ] talks about it press
doesn't talk about it nobody nobody ever
decides just forgot to pay monica
lewinsky probably
yeah all right is that to pay them to
not take it too much
sexual harassment congressional
selection top legal counsel
in the [ __ ] country too so that means
that they're like making sure
that like when nobody talks about it
nobody talks about it
but they're using taxpayer money to pay
these victims
they should be out of their own pockets
it should they should be out of a job
yeah i know no
he's got a point oh you know it's wild
you should be using your own couch for
the casting couch yeah
i don't know if it's pessimistic but i
kind of feel like
it's always going to happen so i'm like
then use your own money don't use mine
yeah i get it
like yeah cause you see the parallels
across the board whether it's like
a priest molesting politicians molesting
or even in the jiu jitsu like high up in
there
everybody's molested everyone's trying
to molest everything the same heinous
[ __ ] happens across any
big organization with hugely powerful
give people power yeah watch what they
do
how can we get people in power to stop
molesting
just [ __ ] stop well first of all
don't use my money to do it
you know what we should do is we should
make one of those videos where we're all
talking to camera and we're like please
stop molesting and then yeah
please stop molesting or what are the
casters saved by the bill yeah we find
this
all the celebrities and then they do
different parts of the song and it's
black and white but what song would go
great for like stop
like a baby shark kind of thing yes
oh but it's a little annoying though
yeah maybe
beatles song or something yo i i heard
that the s epstein stuff wasn't his own
pleasure
but it was a trap to control powerful
people
because they would bring them to the
island and it's all rigged with cameras
and they're doing it already
and then and then they would get these
people on tape
and then they'll be like i need that
favor dude or else i'm going to leak
this [ __ ]
wow and that's not making friends by the
way
that's not a way to make friends yeah
you're not really making friends that
way
dude people don't know that either [ __ ]
yeah
they make friends in a different way
when you're up there i guess you're
coercing people though it's not real
friendship
hey if you don't hang out with me at
pizza i'm gonna show people that you've
been touching other people
that's like the levels of [ __ ] up are
like so far [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i don't know what to be more concerned
about with like theories like that
or concepts is like obviously [ __ ] of
children is like
the worst yeah but then like the using
of the [ __ ] of children really just
for something else like
they're like collateral warfare damages
you know what i mean it's like
here are this fact is it more honorable
if they don't [ __ ] children and they
only use black
male of you [ __ ] children you know
what i mean yeah oh because they're not
[ __ ] them at all at all but they're
blackmailing you in on it like they're
working on you to molest the kids like
drug dealers
yeah i don't know building environments
where
i think that's more awkwardly yeah or or
it's more of a to catch a predator
situation
like a chris hanson situation yeah well
i mean but then you don't have to [ __ ]
the kids
using the kids you don't have to you
just use the kid there as the
and then they come in and then you get
them right not really kid
reality check the kids got [ __ ] i know
i know i know
but that's why you flip it you flip it
you flip it and you make the kids like
you make sure the kids don't get [ __ ]
you protect the kids
but you use them as a placeholder to
lure these congress somebody did a bad
job with
making sure the kids didn't get screwed
yeah but the fc stuff that he was just
you know he crazy
twisted theory right so the first one is
um
trapping these guys to to
to to commit these acts of crime and
then
they uh basically blackmail that's one
method
another method is you want to be a part
of this special club
we rule the world yeah but
yeah but the only way i'm gonna trust
you is if you kill this dude
if you [ __ ] this girl if you do this and
we record you doing it
and we have this evidence and now you're
one of us
because you have shared dirt yeah yeah
yeah cause they're shared risk
[ __ ] up clubs out there there are
where they do [ __ ] like this
and then they they got [ __ ] on each
other because you can't just go based
off of the honor system be like i won't
screw you over bro
yeah especially when you're at that
level so that's another theory too is
like
in order to become a part of this club
you had to go through the epstein
program
and then do these [ __ ] up crimes i
have a theory about epstein i think that
he
he killed himself because he couldn't
stand with stomach what he had done
oh you think he's just guilty
modern day samurai committing seppuku
and [ __ ] to try and regain the last
moment of honor i know he goes i
dishonor everybody
he had that movie moment where he's
staring at his reflection in the water
of the toilet
bowl and he goes what have i become no
then the song from mulan took place
which one reflection i'll make a man out
of you
if they defeated played either of those
on loop i'd kill myself too yeah
i am maybe that's how he killed himself
interested like what the [ __ ] there's
some new ones
no dude with colleen yeah with the whole
epstein-gellaine thing i'm so interested
in why is it taking so [ __ ] long
but you know what's gonna happen nothing
but you know what's
wild though is like okay think about
even five years ago or just maybe five
to eight years ago right
these type of things being openly talked
about in mainstream america
was never a possibility never let's
change that huh
i feel like netflix changes they can
just independently release yeah
never we would hear these things but now
it's like
it's it's as if americans are jaded
they're just like yeah that's true
when americans hear that they're being
spied on like through wikileaks and all
this [ __ ] they're like i know i know
whatever that's what blows my [ __ ]
mind dude yeah
like snowden will tell you tell you not
to even have a [ __ ] phone because
they're they're
they're tapping into your microphone you
won't even know and
we're just like yeah but i like my phone
yeah instagram yeah
we're not career criminals yeah so i'm
not really that
scared like which is why back to this
question if you were a career
oh what would you do what the hell would
you do
what art thief bro come on that's it
that's what we that's a little that's
what nick says right
okay what i think the better question is
what crimes have you committed in your
youth
because whatever your career trajectory
is
it's whatever you were doing frequently
of of that so like if it was stealing
you're probably going to upgrade into
being a heist person
uh or like a big time feat i'm burning
burning cds for the homies
then you are uh uh international
uh blue lake manufacturing leg guy
that's why i said i wanted to get into
counterfeit luxury goods who wants to be
in me and steve's heist crew
come on please please you guys were oh
yeah he's a target thief
i'm a target thief charger you got in
trouble for stealing a target no i
didn't get in trouble bro like come on
you guys are thieves of socks and and
medical supplies yeah
i mean it's useful at least sometimes
you steal things that are way stupider
that you don't even use more than twice
like do you like heist movies
i [ __ ] love i just love a good heist
movie i love the computer guy he's
always my favorite who would you be
which guy would you be i think i'd be
that try to be the computer guy
audition for the spot yeah but if i have
to set up a mobile hospital or something
i'm probably [ __ ]
you want to be the hot girl oh yeah
you're the hot girl that distracts
everybody
i think i like to get the keycard i like
the stethoscope guy
oh and then i like it when they when
they open it without looking after
they're done they're like this
and they go yeah i love that
i think that opens open i think i could
be the getaway driver oh that's a good
one i'll make sure i look
before i emerge are you good can you do
a u-turn in one one move or
you do a three-point turn yeah i could
do one move you know
he could always do the 180 and driving
backwards just as fast yeah
i could drive backwards pretty well you
drift both ways
this guy hasn't he's never seen me
[ __ ] trip both places guys
all three ways not the crew bro it's
just me and steve
yeah dude this is our first time meeting
the crew together i want to start big
though i want to see the [ __ ]
declaration of independence yeah
yeah out the gate you don't want to do
that [ __ ] because nobody's actually done
it just nicholas cage didn't try to do
it in a movie out the cage
you know what the best role is where you
don't commit a crime but you get money
still
the lookout oh true the lookout's great
how about the info guy the guy who gives
them the job yeah
oh yeah they go designates the whole
thing fifty percent of the time though
that guy's the
actually the bad guy right it's like the
reservoir dogs restaurant the cafe guy
the cafe guy the reservoir dogs egg
right
or is the cat the restaurant mission
impossible in the beginning or you're
just the cook
at the restaurant that they do the shady
[ __ ] in the back but you're the cook
they always pass you
they always then you just go
for some reason it's fine right i think
joe's the mouthpiece that's who he is
i tell on everybody no no
you're out of the crew bro you're the
double they're still in the decoration
you guys are here they're here the high
school's here
that's what a mouthpiece is no what is
it what is it no you're the smooth
talker you're the one yeah i i just talk
into the situation
so he's the guy who pretends he's the
tourist to go see the declaration of
independence and he's walking
and then he takes off his wig and his
fake nose and he's like we're in
and then at the end he goes it was him
the whole time
yeah joe goes up to the security guard
who's the lady he's like he's like i
like
watch porn i like i like to let someone
lick my ass
[Laughter]
next thing you know cut scene he's
getting his ass licked in the restroom
by the security lady
and he's the lookout eddie's delicious
jason stay them in the italian job yeah
yeah
the italian job bro your hands are right
because you got the chips to come over
me like this
and then the heads here i'm more like
i'm more like this
on my hat and while she's on his ass
he's like
got him takes him off while he's getting
his ass heated
because it's hot in there it's way too
hot in there
you're clear that's the story of how the
declaration of independence was yeah
yeah it's the catalyst well what do we
do with it yeah we sell it
i don't know we're gonna fence it oh
someone wants to buy it thieves just to
just wipe out the hand on john hancock
dude we pawn it i gotta please sell to
sell to china
[Music]
but the life is too long but the line is
too long we're like [ __ ]
guy who does declaration of advances i
don't know we gotta call it the guy it's
350. you gotta call in the guy
i gotta i gotta have the declaration
independence of my story i'm saying
it's a big pain in the ass i got people
coming through they might buy it and
then chubby comes and spills coffee on
ah
alright 250 250 daddy's like [ __ ]
chug
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] declaration uh now we gotta
go steal something else
we only got 250 for the ten commandments
oh steal the ten commandments
still the gods the constitution man oh
[ __ ]
how did they not do that at the next
national treasure movie yes
we hey we gotta beat them to it bro we
gotta kill them straight from moses dude
we'll steal the bible
which one your time holds the ones at
the hotels
the red sea scrolls but go to a motel
got it
yeah that's true oh my god steal the
alien in uh area 51
bible one one that should be our
high series just stealing stupid [ __ ]
hey what's stupid about stealing
decoration in the past true or the area
51
alien we got to find the buyer first
guys
area 51 is gonna be the the fast 11.
that's gonna be that's what we gotta we
gotta steal
the heinz ketchup recipe oh dude
coca-cola recipe
no joke or kfc yeah in and out secret
sauce recipes
yup dude we got plenty of things to
steal yeah it's hell issues
we're starting real low though but it's
good we gotta we kind of buy her it's
mcdonald's
mcdonald's wants the 10 commandments
dude we steal the queen in england bro
yeah
yeah we take her to the pot stars
we don't know how much she's worth how
much is she worth what do you think i
got a guy it's really her
it's really don't tell me if it's fake
dude don't tell me you know what we
gotta make this
show dude we have no fence that's not a
show on tv where you just totally get
caught
like don't you guys have a discreet way
of offering these goods like no
just tv shows we're doing a document
we're doing a
if you brought the queen with both shoes
on should be worth way more but she only
has one shoe
that's how you get that's how you get
your lots to shoot granted
you're willing to work with a show i'll
get you guys full immunity you sell
around punster
[Laughter]
with a e dude we're a and [ __ ] e we
can get you out of jail
you're still [ __ ] stonehedge and [ __ ]
bringing pawn stars
is wrong with us he's the pawn star man
the pyramid this is like despicable me
now right the villain who steals like
[ __ ]
eiffel tower we still like the statue of
yeah liberty it was like it's one of its
kind come on man you know it's been
missing
[ __ ] dude we need to start the other way
around go to pawn stars and go what's
the most expensive [ __ ]
because we keep bringing fees in here
and we keep getting hit with
percent off we gotta start with local
questions
i feel like the experts that they hire
are always in on it to lobe all the guys
always oh yeah it's not that expensive
they're always like winking at each
other
and he's like oh he's like yeah i do uh
old civil war guns like cool how busy
are you
sitting in a dark room for a [ __ ]
five months at a time
waiting for a phone call people make it
quick i got another place i gotta be
you know too busy to get queen elizabeth
i know
queen elizabeth is the best in heist
though he's still the queen of the
olympia
stonehenge you gotta think [ __ ] i'm
next level you gotta think [ __ ] big
always wow it's rare
it's petty ass [ __ ] i know man
you gotta think big guys i got the moon
you gotta be at least a billion dollars
it's that moment when you're like all
right what's
what's the job right somebody's like
tyreese is trying to walk up there
elaine maxwell
but then we'd be getting her out yeah
that's true oh yeah that's more right
there
we're honorable that's more honorable
still the prison that's holding her
yeah yeah the whole building
justin who does the the fast and furious
movies justin
lynch send them this video dude yeah i
guarantee some of the [ __ ] will be in
there yeah
heist boys i'm waiting for the blueprint
more right just clears the table
rolls it out it's [ __ ] queen
elizabeth right here stonehenge right
here
he's always here eagle rock rock the
eagle rock rock what is that
the rock that looks like an eagle that's
why it's called eagle rock really dude
the best thing
about that rock
the beginning of the fast movie like
tyreese and those guys they're all
scoping out buckingham palace and like
the guards don't even [ __ ] move dude
we got this [ __ ]
and then and then as soon as they're
doing the heist the guards move and
they're like oh [ __ ] the guard's moving
what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
yeah they're super soldiers you said
they don't [ __ ] move luckily the rock
comes in
followed by [ __ ] john cena breaks out
of his cash followed by vin diesel again
that'll be
dope dude
you